never stop hustling
just complain complain complain
and then you win
what can you do what can you do
oh knights f6
it's going for some prepared line here
okay let's see what he's got here
this is a it's an old line
usually i think white is a little bit
better here
but
the only worry is that you will probably
know it better than i do
um
what do you play here f3 i guess
g5
yeah i think rook f2
i'm not so worried about the pen
maybe i'm worried about the pen
and i guess you guys know that you can
spam
um you can spam
with a few exceptions it's mostly it's
mostly fine
um but you can't
as per usual in like
at least half serious matches you cannot
you cannot um cannot suggest moves
and even though we don't have a lot of
moderators
we will ban you
and you can never come back
meanwhile in the game yeah he went 94.
he played this so fast that i suspected
that it was something he knew
um but now i'm getting a little bit less
sure about it
because it seems to me
it seems to me that this end game is
better for me
because of the the bishops
and i'll be interested to see how he
intends to
try and equalize here i got c4
rook d8 rook b2
potentially
and if he trades i have a
potentially strong passport so he goes
rex c8
makes a lot of sense guess now rook d2
rook behind potential pass pawn
centralizing
i didn't see 95 though
that's really annoying
really really annoying
oh boy yeah now there's no question of
me having an advantage
now i probably need to see how i can
equalize
okay let's go c5
hoping for rook fd8
plus this
and bishop well there's still not b3
even this one doesn't work
he actually went rook fd8
it's annoying
okay let me try
and get a little bit cheeky here
i have some
serious tactics in mind so the line i
have in mind is rook t2 bishop d2
knight beat oh sorry knight b3
bishop b7
which i'm gonna have to play fast of
course but i think this should probably
work
rook c7
yeah maybe even bishop f4 works there
rick b7 and then c6
but i was thinking rook c7 c6
if knight d2 i rook d1
okay but maybe bishop f4 is actually
stronger
i think bishop f4 is stronger
oh no it's maybe it's not bishop f4 rp7
c6 rook b8 is an amazing trick
because i have to play c6 now obviously
time is time is running out but that's
one of the good things about playing
three two that you have a little bit
extra time for all of this
bishop a5 and i don't think he can stop
my pawn
rook e7 c7 hp6 there's bishop t5
which probably means that i'm better
if he has to if he has to give up the
rook for the pawn then
my bishop pair will probably reign
supreme
on an open board
okay so he's maybe gonna try bishop e6
yeah i think he's trying this and now
rook c7
and then rook f7 which i guess is
sensible
let me bring the king in still believe
that my bishop is better than his knight
um yeah king goes
i think this ending should be close to
winning for me now
bishop d2 i think i want to go a for a5
or just king c6 actually maybe just king
c6
yeah let's go king b5 yeah i want to
keep his king out a little bit
b3
oh knight d3 he's going for counter play
okay i know i have to play faster
obviously
i still think i have enough pawns to win
here
did i seriously just blunder my bishop
that way
oh my god
didn't even pay attention to the bishop
unbelievable
oh yeah it's really poor
okay draw
i was playing a good game here at some
point i mean
just move the bishop king e6 king f7 on